let's see how you we're using these tips
and tools that I've given you with a
different kind of question when I just
let you have it go okay I want to read
carefully so I'm gonna look at the
question and it says the great gals it
makes it the great gals are having your
Salem microwave ovens the sale price of
each oven is listed below along with the
discount now that's actually really
weird
you read that carefully it says the sale
price is listed I know about you I mean
usually you see you know oh this is the
amount and then you work out the
discount and you sort of have to do in
your head oh it's 30% off this so then
you have to take that off they've
already taken it off okay so when it
says save $20 it doesn't take $20 off
whatever is there the marked price
they've already removed it okay so the
first thing I'm writing is sale price so
that I don't blindly just think on what
is that $149 what's it about I know
exactly what it's about a question tells
me okay that second number of course
they're the discount and I'm just doing
the first microwave Esther okay Part A
says calculate the original price
original price so that's kind of nice
the question will often tell you the
language you need to use right so all
right
original price I want to give me an
answer
yeah Jamie yeah fantastic I'm doing 149
plus 20 and that's yeah that's simple
enough for us to do in our heads isn't
it
169 days your original price are you
gonna pop be really careful because
there's lots of parts to it that you
need to dissect calculate to one decimal
place the percentage discount on each
oven give me a suggestion what should I
write before I start any numbers can you
take us yeah they did
Oh what am I gonna write what am i doing
yeah the puddin George yeah okay um I'm
going to because I used through a
discount there
I'm gonna go percentage discount cuz
that's actually what I want to calculate
yeah okay Fran I want to give me a
suggestion wish I go - yep
okay now I clearly need to bring these
letters together in some particular
order right the discount is here there's
the discount but to get a percentage
discount I'm going to be dividing by now
which one the sale price or the original
price what do you reckon it's gonna be
the original price right because you've
already taken it off here so therefore
I'm dividing by 169 in fact that's kind
of why Part A says work out the original
price point okay calculator worked out
calculator this is gonna give you a
decimal okay now I'm getting what does
that check out that way okay now hold on
hold on this is just what the calculator
has told me does that make sense so
father now how do I go to a percentage I
multiply by a hundred right so that's
eleven point
bah-bah-bah percent does that make sense
please note by the way like from this
line to this line the number changes cuz
percent gets added on so don't just say
that cuz zero point one one is not equal
to eleven it's equal to 11 percent okay
now what kind of approximation are they
asking me for I wanted to do one decimal
place so there's the first decimal place
I look at the next one does that go up
or down because it's a three right
it goes down yeah so this is
approximately equal to eleven point
eight percent one decimal place